hey youtubers it's Charlie so a whole
bunch of news about the Batman movie the
flash movie and then stuff that's
happening in the TV universe so there's
a whole bunch of Batman related stuff
happening this week including in the
Marvel Universe to Batman stuff in the
Marvel Universe they're all explained a
lot of cool Batman things happening
right now but like the biggest news is
that the CEO of Time Warner said that
the Batman movie that Ben Affleck is
making is about 18 months off which is
actually some pretty good information
previously you know Ben Affleck had just
said
well we'll make it when I'm ready to
make it I'm not gonna rush it which is
really what you want to hear like you
don't want to hear them announce a date
that's in like a year so it's like well
how they gonna shoot and edit that like
when are they gonna make the script that
was one of the biggest problems with
Suicide Squad like you had a lot of
really good things but not just quite
enough time to work on the script so
they're still working on the Batman
script obviously they're not gonna shoot
it for a while but once they shoot a
film it takes about a year to turn it
around maybe a little bit less than a
year so you have to imagine that like in
the next six months we're gonna be
hearing a lot more about what's going on
with the Batman movie but that isn't
really like a firm date that's just the
CEO saying that based on the progress
that they're making now the movies about
18 months off so that could change they
could get six months down the road and
say hey you know this script just isn't
ready yet so there's no reason to rush
it so let's just push it by like another
six months or another year so the very
earliest I would expect to see a Batman
film would be like spring it'll probably
be a spring movie whenever they do drop
it
spring 2018 or 2019 and I'm not gonna be
surprised at all if they push it to 2019
if that's what it takes to make it a
really awesome film it's gonna be almost
impossible to follow Christopher Nolan
even though Dark Knight Rises wasn't
quite as good as everyone hoped it was
gonna be Dark Knight is still the best
Batman film of all time and even though
I think Ben Affleck's version of Batman
could eventually transcend that like
you're gonna do him like a much cooler
version of Batman it's just gonna take
time to get there
we know the Deathstroke is in it we know
that it's going to be a Gotham based
movie it's gonna involve Arkham Asylum
there'll be a prison break element to it
sort of seeding the larger DC movie
universe with villains well you know
what's better than when you're trying to
play
seeds for future movies then unleashing
villains all over your earth you're not
only creating material for future Batman
movies because the story of him tracking
those are the villains down that have
escaped is a whole other movie but you
also create new Suicide Squad movies too
because what are they for if not taking
down big villains that are too dangerous
for normal people to take down but if
you haven't seen it I have talked a
little bit about Suicide Squad movie
plans they're rumors behind the scenes
that they've sort of changed course a
little bit pushed the next Suicide Squad
sequel the next direct sequel to like
way off in favor of moving up a Harley
Quinn movie but it would be like her
movie with Joker in it I mean it's like
margot robbie producing and developing
the movie so even though there's a lot
of stuff changing behind the scenes at
Warner Brothers once you know once they
all announced the stuff official dates
and stuff like that it'll all make sense
it'll look like your traditional lineup
that Marvel might release I think people
have grown used to that where they say
when each of the movies is coming out
and then they might swap a couple movies
that are way later on Marvel's kind of
done that with like a man the wasp they
originally move that up the schedule
they just announced that they push
Doctor Strange
so that they could get Benedict
Cumberbatch because originally they
hadn't intended to start making that
movie earlier than they did but more
really cool Batman stuff if you didn't
see it I just posted a new Supergirl
trailer with Superman in it they named
drop Gotham there were a lot of people
that thought that they named dropped mr.
Wayne as in Batman himself when
Superman's on the phone he's talking to
Perry White he says mr. white not mr.
Wayne so they do talk about Gotham they
do not talk about Batman which is a
slightly different thing but there will
be Batman characters on Supergirl but
not like bat woman Batman Batgirl not
Batman characters in that way you just
have to imagine that people from Gotham
City people from Batman's group of
characters I think the only characters
they've confirmed is bat woman's
girlfriend Kathy Kane's girlfriend in
the comics will be on Supergirl so
Batman characters but not Batman himself
and you do have to remember that because
they are doing a lot of luthorcorp's
stuff that the TV shows have like a
separate continuity from the movies so
even though there are a lot of similar
things happening like Lex Luthor is in
prison on Supergirl
he's in prison in the movies there'll be
a little bit of eye winking officially
they're not connected but I feel like
most people watching will just absorb
that like you just you get that from
watching it like okay this isn't a thing
to do with what's going on in the movies
right now and separately this is
actually really cool talk more about it
during my next agents at shell video but
the new director of shield Jason O'Mara
who's the voice of Batman and some of
the more recent DC animated movies is
playing Jeffrey mace who's the patriot
in the comics who has been one of the
people to wear the mantle of Captain
America now this is in the classic
Captain America comics this version of
the character is obviously a younger
person so he probably has not been
Captain America the only person who's
been Captain America in the movie so far
is Steve Rogers himself so Jeffrey mace
on the TV show is not going to be like a
former Captain America but now we can
make the joke that the Batman version of
Captain America is the new director of
shield so just remember that when you're
watching agents of shield this week but
back to the DC movies so the director of
the flash movie just finished like the
most recent revision of the script
they're still working on the script for
that he teased cyborg like he put this
little like figurine up here at the top
of the page that just meant to give you
the eye wink that yes cyborg is
definitely going to be in the flash
movie I've already done a couple videos
about the flash movie but basically I'm
thinking if it is more of like a STAR
Labs movie it'll take place in and
around Central City because the Rogues
are supposed to be the big villains and
aside from that we don't know much about
it I know everybody wants to know if the
reverse-flash is gonna be it like if you
Bart Thawne is gonna be a part of it
because he's such a big part of Barry's
origin story but you have to remember
that the movies have been changing the
comic book stories just a little bit so
even though I do think that the movie
version of eobard thawne that
reverse-flash will eventually show up in
a flash movie I don't think they're
gonna start there but anything that has
ever been done in a flash comic book is
totally fair game for the flash movies
you know I think the flash movie will be
successful they'll be like a trilogy so
to speak so they'll get to all that
stuff eventually it's just that they're
doing so much with the new gods right
now that I think they want to focus more
on that stuff with the DC movies that
they're all tying together but because
I'm not gonna do a video for it I was
originally gonna do a Gotham video but I
just could not stand Ben Mackenzie's
character so I will say that poison ivy
is now an adult character on Gotham
they're doing court of owls so I will be
watching Gotham this season but I'm
prime not gonna do separate videos I'll
mention got like if they do really crazy
court of owls stuff or they do really
crazy comic-book stuff I'll just mention
it in my Batman related videos because
there will be more Batman movie videos
as the movie start to roll out like
Justice League related stuff so there
are like a lot of new things they're
doing this season that I do like like
Jamie Chung great but I do not like Ben
McKenzie I don't like what they did with
poison ivy but I do think it's cool that
they're doing poison ivy so maybe it'll
turn into something really cool but the
way the writers and the producers are
talking about poison ivy on the TV show
makes it sound like they don't
understand how she works in the comics
like they have their version of poison
ivy nothing like what she is in the
comics and what I am hoping is from the
Harley Quinn movie like on the movie
side of this is that they'll do a Gotham
City sirens type movie with Harley Quinn
at the center in poison ivy we'll get to
be a part of that but remains to be seen
I think Catwoman is the only person that
we can count on to show up in Harley
Quinn but let me know in the comments a
lot of Batman stuff happening when do
you think we'll actually see that Batman
movie and when do you think that we will
see Catwoman in poison ivy like some of
the cooler Batman villains show up in
the movies you have to remember that
Geoff Johns is co-writing the movie with
Ben Affleck and nobody does villains
like Geoff Johns rogues gallery is his
specialty be it flash rogues be it
Batman rogues
so my next video is gonna be a new arrow
trailer I'll talk about the hundredth
episode teasers that Stephen Amell has
been dropping
there's just his picture he dropped of
him casually sitting next to Deathstroke
waiting for them to set up for another
shot so Deathstroke is in the hundreds
episode in Manu Bennett separately on
Facebook is just like thank you this
made me laugh so much that I'll talk
more about that when I post that arrow
video so that'll post a little while and
then we'll have new agents of shield
Ghost Rider there's so much stuff to
drop today there's even new Doctor
Strange stuff Kevin Feige confirmed
Marvel multiverse
so be sure to subscribe to get it and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Ben Reed you win a gift
certificate for the flash season 2
blu-ray just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details so I'll try
to get through all that stuff as fast as
possible and there might even be some
new flash footage soon too so a lot of
really cool stuff happening this week
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch that extended
Superman Supergirl trailer again and you
can click here for my teaser for the
arrow hundredth episode thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight